Я просто сделаю быстрый тест, чтобы проверить это работает.
-Все работает? -Перфект.
-Старт recording.
-Старт первый степь, мы создали...
Я не могу остановиться.
Это...
Смотрите, я садил это.
-Старт-сценарий?
-Да, это интермин-менуал тест-сценарий.
So, what we are doing here, it's like a real oppositor going to the website, his price list.
So, we are going to the page, Intermine Pricing.
To pricing.
And for 30 seconds, you need to understand what happens there.
Is it, do you understand what's, what's showed there?
Get onto pricing.
Yeah, this seems pretty standard, easy to understand.
You have very clearly sectored pricing plans
The text is very bold, clear, very easy to understand
The only thing is maybe the monthly to yearly being a toggle or a switch
Is maybe slightly smaller, unclear, I don't know
Just scrolling down
The features, how it explains how each plan affects what you'll have access to
quite clear, I like the use
of the tick symbols
of your FAQ, free trial
work, business include a 14
day free trial, hard to start
nothing is charged until the trial ends
I like the little
drop down menus, they're very easy to navigate
I think the options that you've chosen are very
relevant
the answers
are good, concise
before you pick a plan
I like this as well
It allows people to decide for themselves
And see which part of the service they'd use the most
Taking a look at use cases
Use cases built around multilingual collaboration
Exhibitions and conferences
Multilingual global town halls
I would say very easy to navigate
Very clear and concise
All the symbols are quite aesthetically pleasing
perfect
now we are going to the main page
you need to understand
what's happening there
how much time
it will take you to find
the demo button
without
registration
oh you already done
the FAQ
and read some
landing parts
with the case and reviews
and your comments
sorry, so where do I
where am I going now
give me a second, yeah, now you're going
to the intermine.com without
slash and into the main page, can you
just remove the last part in the
browser, just leave intermine.com
intermine.com, okay
yeah, and
the same thing, describe what you're seeing
just scrolling the page
very clear slogan, straight away
stop running meetings in someone
else's language, intermine
translates voice chat and share docs
live so each person speaks and reads
their own on a sovereign EU
engine that you can audit
yeah
I have a very simple clear description
of what service provides
what it does
then I mean the live
demo is a very clear
button there's the contrast between the
light blue and the dark background
to make it easier to find
and there's the benchmarks as well
your data lives
translation quality
Okay, I see there's a blog here
That's interesting
Is there
Certain parts you want me to go through first
Or just kind of how I would go through
The website
Alright
Okay, I'll try with my part what I'm seeing
I'm on the main page
Intramine.com
I'm seeing that
Slogan is very clear
I see the first
First links
Сверенитет, Ресурс, Методологи, Релиз, Методологи,
Архитектура.
There's double methodology.
I see that
some of the text
is almost
the same color as the background.
So it's a bit hard to read.
And some of the text is extremely small.
Yeah.
I don't see.
I see that on the sovereignty page
some of the numbers
are a bit
not in the center of the circle.
Угу.
Да, я вижу.
"Why interwined?".
Я scrolled немного, чуть-чуть.
Это видно очень clearly.
Давайте посмотрим, как это работает.
"Translate Workshats".
"This page works".
"Real-time translation end-to-end".
Все здесь видно очень clearly.
"Page opens успешно".
Видите, я scroll down.
"Everything's perfect".
"Everything's pretty clear".
Следующий.
"Collaborative meeting workspace".
"Page opens".
Everything looks clear, no bugs.
Okay, next one.
Everything security page opened.
Yeah, everything looks clear in this part.
So, I'm strolling down the main page.
And I see that everything is fine here.
Okay, what's next?
Demo.
Let's try a demo.
I just click on the try a live demo?
Yeah, you can just check the demo by yourself for a few minutes.
What you see, how it works.
So let's try and undermine demo. Page opens successfully. All the standard formatting is correct. There's the video slash animation, how it works. That's all working. Okay, I'm just going to click on start demo.
I do notice that on the description where it says
you'll be asked to allow camera and microphone access,
I think there's a space between the...
The spacing between the letters on some of the demo mode
is a bit strange, but that's just a bit nitpicking.
So I'll just click on Start Demo.
Is that good?
Yep.
Okay, requesting permissions.
The pop-up shows up.
Use your microphones, use your cameras.
I'll allow.
Setting up the demo.
Speak on the left.
Hear translation on the right.
Everything seems to be working well.
It's just loading.
There you go.
You can see me.
My camera's working.
Multiple languages detected.
Participants speak different languages.
I see myself on both sides of the screen.
Let me just see.
So I think, of course I don't speak Dutch.
But I do see that it's translating it.
And I can hear it in my voice, which is very strange.
It's kind of cool.
Just check out some of the settings
So you can turn off the camera
Microphone mutes
So if I speak now, is it still going to go?
Okay, the mute worked
Show participants, works perfectly
How do I close this?
How do I close the participants tab?
The button disappears
Ah, close participants
So that was pretty easy to navigate
Open chat, language detected
So this is a full transcript
Of everything I'm saying
In English
and so I imagine if I
try that on the other side as well
it's going to give a transcript of
I'm sure if there is supposed to be a transcript of
what I'm saying in Dutch here
maybe that's just the
yeah I think that's just the chat
but the chat over here has a transcript
okay let's try the share screen
might be a little bit of
inception
just the entire screen, also share
system audio, yeah I think that
seems to be working but this is creating
like an infinite loop
Смотрите инфинтинфинт луп?
Pardon? Sorry, I can't hear you.
Ты говоришь, что это инфинтинфинт луп?
А, с видео?
А, да, когда вы сэкраните,
вы сэкраните изображение.
Это не проблема.
Есть ли еще...
Эмоте?
Реопен демо.
После изменения.
А, как я изменяю демо?
Я запрещал демо самостоятельно.
There should be a button on new languages, uh...
I can disable translation, uh...
And Russian.
So which...
Oh, I guess both in this.
So, disable translation.
Yeah, then I can just hear myself in English.
Settings.
Translation language.
So, maybe I'll do...
Is there any language you want me to...
Try to change it to Russian, maybe, okay.
Then let me turn to label translation.
Hello, testing.
I cannot speak Russian, but I think maybe I'm mute.
Ah, let's check language translation in the meeting room.
I think that's better.
Сейчас это будет трудно понимать.
Да, и демо?
Да, и демо, и демо.
И демо, и демо.
Демо, и демо, и демо.
Да, и демо, и демо.
Все выглядит практически так же.
Присоединяем английский язык.
Все выглядит так же.
Я не думаю, что ничего не изменилось.
Я не знаю, что это рандомат.
Я думаю.
Демо.
Добавил субтитры DimaTorzok
И я вижу, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно имеем в том, что мы все равно не можем.
И я начну с новой программой.
Да, я просто перенам с новой программой.
Я просто перенам с новой программой.
Я буду делать 5 минут минут, потому что я думаю, что я не буду говорить.
Я буду говорить о моем комнате.
Да, я буду делать 5 минут.
Я буду делать 5 минут.